my bangs look okay all right amber amber
uh were you from merchants where'd you
grow up um I was born in rate while I
was born in Los Angeles and then I was
moved to Upland California which is in
the Inland Empire and then from there I
moved to Woodley Hills not in this area
you grew up with both your parents well
my mom yes and then my real dad got
killed the same day my mom and my
stepdad got married the exact same day
yeah how'd your dad die
he got killed murdered mm-hmm I was 5
August 7 my 73 what was he getting in
trouble a lot or something like that um
he was in the streets he was a gang
member he's a drug dealer he was a big
drug dealer okay so that lifestyle yeah
and what kind of kid were you in high
school
um by the time I hit high school I was
already like out of control really let's
let's back up to your childhood yeah how
was it Charlie um around the age I want
to say 11 my mom started going through
depression
depression runs I want to say it runs in
our family but it's like I guess
hereditary because my great-grandmother
had it my grandmother had a and then my
mom got it I was 11 my little brother
was 5 so when she went into her
depression I had to step up and be the
momma so I would take care of my brother
I will wake him up get him ready for
school walk him to school pick him up
from school do homework with him I was a
mother like I was literally my first
child so when my dad took him because my
stepdad I call him my dad my stepdad
took him at that point I was in high
school so now I had a little bit of
freedom and I went crazy with that a
little bit of freedom this was around
high school every joke whoo um writing
away from home I didn't want to be at
home because I wasn't getting the love
at home because my mom was going through
what she was going through so I was
looking for that love in the streets and
it was a good I was partying and
drinking and turned hanging out with
older people I always looked older
well younger always looks older so they
didn't know really how old I was but I
was with older men and then it just got
to out and then my stepdad he came and
snatched me took me to the valley at
that time I was 16 17
sixteen so as a young teenager you were
already like 80 guys my first boyfriend
was 26 I was 13
what were you like getting guys for
money um at that time no at that time I
think I was just looking for that love
that I wasn't getting so and younger my
body always looked older like I had the
bigger boobs I didn't look like a normal
11 13 year old so at that time no I
wasn't looking because when I went to
the valley
I was already still used so that
lifestyle that I was living
so me and my stepdad would clash cuz I
wouldn't come home I would run away from
home I didn't want to be there because I
was so used to having my freedom so then
at that time I was like homeless so I
met a guy it was like well if you come
stay with me you could come stay with me
you know you can live your lifestyle but
we're gonna do this on the side so that
we able to pay for rent and that
lifestyle decide was dancing because
like I said I always had a body so and I
always loved to dance so he's like you
might as well get paid for it might as
well put you on or I could put you
somewhere at this time I wasn't even 18
yet he was like I know I know somewhere
we can dance you know they're not gonna
worry about your age so I went into the
club I was dancing at this club maybe
I'm gonna say maybe a year and I had a
regular toilet come in all the time and
I don't want to say he followed me to my
car one night and then he raped me
that's still kind of bothers me to this
day to work after work it so
[Music]
I don't know it still has a toll on me
to this day I'm sure okay how many years
ago was this you were 17
no at this time I was 18 and I didn't
want to do it anymore because I'm scared
like to go to work I didn't know but
staying with the guy he would make me so
it was like forced so I just kept doing
it I kept doing it and now it was like
my go-to still to this day is still my
go-to like I don't want to do it but I
know I could go to it it's my go-to if I
ever need to a lot of people don't know
that so about the the rape situation but
after I feel like after the rape
situation I feel like I turn to sex
I started doing it more I started I
don't know it felt like I don't know how
to say it but it was like I felt like I
don't know some some people say like
when you get raped you can go one or two
ways I felt like I went the wrong way I
felt like I should should have went
about it differently but I I think I got
more out of control after the rape yes I
started drinking turned into six I was
having sex crazy like didn't care I
don't know if that's normal but yeah it
was like I wanted it like I needed it I
had to have it and then yeah I just wish
I would have went differently after that
I have instead of going the road that I
would do so you're so you're so
stripping today yes
not like regularly like that's not like
my there's just my go-to I know that I
can go to the club and dance and that
that's the kind of job where you can
kind of come and go as you please yeah
that'd be 9:00 to 5:00 every day no no
no I mean no I wouldn't make that my
regular job I did that to where it was
my regular job where I was dependent on
that money where that money was if I
didn't dance I wasn't gonna have no
money I wouldn't go back to that what
are the worst things about being a
stripper um for the best things what are
the worst things of course the best
things is the money of course I think
the worst things is a lot of people I
don't know like a lot of people try to
put strippers like oh you're just going
to that it's more to it than that
it's like you got to work where that
money just like anybody else has to it
doesn't just come to you then we'll it
takes a toll on your body because a lot
of people know you can't go dance
sober you can't you have to drink you
have to take you know you have to ease
yourself so a lot of people do drugs a
lot of people drink a lot of people so
it takes a toll on your body after a
while dancing on your knees my knees is
some old now and I'll be like whoa you
know so but your dancing is not it's not
as easy as people think it is just like
a prostitute
you got to learn you got to get to you
got to get a trick because your trick is
where your money come from
you need it in the strip club you got to
have a trick too because you gotta have
a regular you got at you have to you
have to have to like just going in and
dancing and not knowing I conversating
like like I said you got to work for
your money just like anybody else
but a lot of people really think
stripping is easy it's not it's really
it's really really really not and you
also deal with a lot like now to this
day when I do go dance I'm still scared
cuz you never know you might just get
that one person that just can't separate
the club like what happened when I got
raped so I'm still scared I always have
somebody go with me I never go by myself
so it's like it's like a lot we have to
deal with as well and then another thing
that shippers deal with too cuz I've had
it
when you do get a regular and irregular
does come in the club with you they form
a relationship with you that you don't
even know that they have they become
obsessed with you they become and I feel
like that's what happened when I got
raped
he didn't want to take no for an answer
and you get a lot of those you get a lot
of those so it's a scary job but it's
like it's my goal to lose like that's
her money I don't know I really need
money I know I couldn't go to that so
kids and yes I have kids the story with
them goes back kind of to when I was
running the wildlife they get pregnant I
didn't have kids and me being so used to
being free and being wild and being I
had to make a decision to let my kids go
not let them go but I knew at that time
I couldn't be a mother to them
so I rather my kids be somewhere where I
know they were safe take a care of loved
sorry
but yeah I have kids you say that a
stone of course yes I still see them no
they know who I am really say what and
they say when I step that but yeah
that's a heart it was a hard decision to
make
but I had to I couldn't I couldn't have
them run in the streets with me I
couldn't have them here they're
everywhere
so as a mother I had to make that
decision and I felt like it was a good
to say well if I mean it has this visit
as bad because of course you're not you
want to be with your kids but I know
that well taken care of they're so smart
and my dad did a good job with them
that's right
so sorry
it's the sensitive subject but yes you
just saw contact with the rest of your
family
um I felt like I don't have a family I
feel like myself that kind of plays a
part in my kids that's all I had kids
because I wanted to start my own family
but being so wrapped up in that
lifestyle I just cut it and the family
that I do have we don't talk
you know communicate we don't i'm
literally by myself my dad's side of the
family I don't talk to them at all my
mom's side of the family I don't know
him I said that family kind of when I
got older and that's so Wow it was just
like they really don't have that much to
do with me so it's like I'm really out
here by myself
and I feel like that's why I am the way
that I am I don't let people in I don't
have a tough skin like
I have friends that you know I've been
friends with for a long time I consider
them my family but family I don't have
no family I don't know what family is
you see your kids like on holidays and
things like that um yes I do like I say
they know who I am you know you know I'm
mom
they're still kind of young they don't
know like why is my mom with this every
day
but when they get older you know I'll
explain to them and hopefully they
understand it because what I need won't
was for my kids to feel I felt but it
was a little different because I was in
the home with my mom but I still didn't
get that love I still didn't get my mom
didn't teach me anything I know
everything on my own period it's to
having sex that's probably why I was so
crazy because I didn't know what was
right I didn't know what was wrong what
do you wish was different about your
childhood that might have changed the
direction of my um I always say the love
because I turned to the streets for the
love cuz I wasn't getting it at home so
I wanted to go get it from somewhere so
I felt like if I had that in home love I
really don't feel like I would have
turned out how I did
yeah I wish that would have been
differently but it's like well like I
wouldn't be Who I am without going
through what I went through but I would
I would have hoped I didn't wait
differently when you say you a stripper
needs to indulge in something in order
to just do the work what drug do you
typically go to do and well I don't
really do drugs I was doing ecstasy
pills though I turned I had my stage of
that and I had a really bad episode with
that so I stopped doing that so then I
just turned to alcohol I would get drunk
I wouldn't care
blackout fallout I didn't care that was
my go-to now I don't really drink as
much because of my situations in my
episodes but yet my drug of choice was
ecstasy pills and I had a really bad
experience with it so I just stopped but
I've never done you know any other drug
but ecstasy pills are addicting as well
because I was addicted to it
like I would crave for them I will go
through the withdrawals and I having
them and then yeah I took a ecstasy pill
that I thought was an ecstasy pill and
it was something else it was as soon as
bad so I just stopped
I'm always around it though I'm always
around drugs I just chose not to do
drugs because what I've seen growing up
you know what the drugs my mom doing
drugs so I didn't it I was never me so
then when I did try to give a drug a
chance
it went all bad so just okay no yeah so
I turned to drinking a kids say that I
was like a alcoholic for maybe two to
three years and then I was like this
because I've
I don't like the feeling of something
taking over my body and me not being
able to control it or me being able to I
don't like that feeling so it was like I
had to get myself together because I was
losing myself and then I fell into that
I did that depression mode because that
goes back to what I was saying like it
runs like it's hereditary and I tried to
commit suicide
so that was like after I did that I
tried to block everything out so I don't
really drink anymore I don't like I
don't do did you try to come the end of
last year no you try I took pills and
somebody walked in I want to say I guess
at the right time and they call the
ambulance and I woke up in the hospital
but I was at the point in life I don't
want to be here anymore oh Jesus what do
you think keeps you from wanting to just
get your life together just for your
kids right now that's what I'm going
through I'm going through getting myself
together I'm going through trying to get
myself better because it's good but but
I guess what I'm saying is people will
watch this and like oh that's that's an
obvious that's obviously the smart
decision but but I understand it it's
much more complex than that yeah it's
easier said than done
it's wait wait I'm trying to figure out
what what it is that is it in play that
keeps you from just being able to make
that simple decision
I want to say because when you get used
to a lifestyle it's hard to just let it
go it's been times where I'll try to
okay look I'm gonna get it together like
I got to get my kids and then you fall
back into that lifestyle and then it's
just like I'm back to square one
do you think some of those just your
self-worth is you must believe you
deserve the treatment that you get out
in the street or in the strip club or
whatever I want it maybe maybe it's I'm
used to it cuz that's all I know
but it's like now it's like okay I have
to it's like it's it's it's not good for
me because that lifestyle is what made
me take those pills it made me not want
to be here anymore it made me not
it was just like enough was enough and
that's why I wanted to kill myself
that's why I didn't want to be here
anymore but then it's just like now I
have to look at the situation like I
have people I have little people that
look up to me so it's like I have to get
myself together I've never had a regular
job I just got a regular job so it's
like I'm just I'm trying I just have to
keep myself from falling back into that
lifestyle so it's it's it's hard it's
it's way easier said than done but I
have to because it's like now it's like
I'm getting older I'm not getting
younger so I don't have that much time I
have to I have to and then my kids are
getting older so it's like now they're
gonna understand now they're gonna know
now they're gonna see their mom know
like I don't that's what I don't want
that's what I fear because I know how
that feels because I went through that
and I don't want my kids
that excellent all right amber thank you
so much for talking to me thank you good
bye with me with your kids and
everything thank you you know how do you
hear crying
you